celle-là c'est chanter
de son
assurance une certaine culpabilité
pourquoi j'ai pas été plus intelligent
que les autres
mais non on fait pas ça pas de bon sens
il a joué lui aussi ok junior majeur
avant d'être recruté dans la LNH
quand les scandales d'initiation
dégradantes ont éclatées Enrico tu
connais assiégé à la commission
parlementaire il faudrait peut-être le
rendre public le rapport il a souvent
commenté les travaux printemps il
s'ouvre pour la première fois sur ce que
ça provoqué chez lui sa remise en
question tout ce qui est arrivé là on
est venu ouvrir un tiroir qui est
affirmé à jamais il
n'a pas lui-même
humiliante mais en a été témoin c'était
très très personnel à certains moments
mais je me suis dit
je veux laisser quelque chose je pense
que là ok le monde va hockey la culture
de hockey avait besoin d'une Commelle
l'expression d'un bon coin sur la gueule
la Commission a suggéré d'écrire
mère faire quoi que ce soit sans
consentement mais le rapport n'a pas
force de loi tant que le gouvernement ne
s'en inspire pas pour légiférer ce qu'il
compte faire à l'automne ce genre de
recommandations là
si elle est acceptée c'est un
Omron je vous ai fait un coup de circuit
parce que c'est une industrie privée
c'est comme la Ligue nationale
c'est tout des propriétaires c'est eux
qui décident mais la pression sur eux
est tellement forte
commission là-dessus jamais jamais parce
qu'on n'aurait jamais dû être obligé de
se rendre là
cesser c'est c'est pathétique que
législateur soit obligé de zéro ça va
faire il espère au moins une chose de
protéger
peut-être le prochain Rico
peut-être de faire une niaiserie qu'ils
veulent ce qu'il leur est suivi leur
assassiné peut-être à 52 ans 53 ans qui
sera coupable aujourd'hui ici Véronique
prince Radio-Canada Québec